alors qu'on parle beaucoup de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre regardez ce qu'on vous
présente à l'écran c'est une nouvelle
campagne de sensibilisation que vous
allez voir de plus en plus au cours des
prochains jours dans le cadre de la
semaine de la réhabilitation sociale du
québec qui débute demain avec moi daniel
belson kyi et porte-parole du comité
consultatif pour la clientèle
judiciariser adultes conseiller en
intervention aussi l'addition aux bruits
et conférencier monsieur benson bonjour
on joue à tout d'abord on vous connaît
dans les médias monsieur benson parce
que on le rappelle d'entrée du joueur
vous avez purgé une peine
d'emprisonnement de dix sept ans vous
êtes sorti de prison vous en 1999 et
depuis quinze ans je travaille beaucoup
pour la réhabilitation des anciens début
de ce mois là c'est une cause qui vous
tient à coeur mais c'est une cause qui
me tient à coeur et je crois que les
gens qui ont commis un délit peut
importe le délit si on travaillait sur
eux
lyon doit de reprendre leur place dans
la société chaque commence souvent par
la peau de l'emploi et donc vous vous
impliquez beaucoup dans cette campagne
de sensibilisation dont je parlais pour
faire en sorte que les employeurs
regarde la clientèle et les gens qui
peuvent avoir un casier judiciaire de
façon plus positive par exemple dans
leurs démarches de recherche d'emploi
il faudrait que les employeurs regarde
d'abord les qualités de la personne
avant de regarder kg judiciaire parce
que quelqu'un qui a un casier judiciaire
est observé sur toutes les formules
d'employeurs la section besoins quasi
commis un acte criminel
sonko choi c'est 50% de chances de moins
ça vaut des fois jusqu'à 80% de change
de moins d'obtenir un emploi donc
faudrait que les employeurs regarde les
qualités de la personne puis voir ça
peut faire une différence dans leurs
oeufs dans leur entreprise également et
quand on parle de casier judiciaire ça
peut être toutes sortes de délits ça
peut être une sorte de crime sap et
l'alcool au volant vous savez vous
tournez les jeunes qui terminent des
sessions d'université bientôt le pré n'a
pas de trou soit arrêté par la police
lyon un casier judiciaire un problème
que le volant donc c'est pas
nécessairement des gens qui ont commis
des crimes énorme c'est son piano mais
la grande majorité ce n'est pas des gens
qui ont commis des crimes très très
grand et vous dites donc dans une
contexte de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
ça pourrait être une solution
intéressante il faut regarder cette
clientèle ou parce que cette clientèle
l'observer pour se rincer la société
parce que les lits jalil les monsieur
madame tout le monde les entreprises ont
un devoir social à l'égard de notre
société
et moi je dis souvent que pour se
redresser la société
après entre autres ça prend un toit un
réseau social et un emploi et le pot de
l'emploi ben va permettre d'avoir un
toit qui va permettre de se refaire un
réseau social
donc c'était essentiel et en faisant
soit en engageant des gens qui ont un
casier judiciaire
bon on protège la société parce qu'on
diminue le taux de récidive par le même
temps qu'est ce qu'ils disent les
employeurs ils ont déterré de sens
bayonne
1 étude qui a été fait dans la région de
la mauricie et 72 % des employeurs
avaient des réticences à embaucher
quelqu'un 15 un casier judiciaire
et pourquoi comprenez je comprends pas
ce qu'un casier judiciaire ça fait peur
mais il faut aller gratter un petit peu
en arrière de sourds c'est quoi le cas
jusqu'à qu'est ce qui a amené la
personne à avoir un casier judiciaire
vous savez il ya personne qui se lève un
matin qui décide d'aller faire des
délits et un chemin qui menait gens sur
est généralement les gens qui ont un
casier judiciaire particulièrement ceux
qui ont eu des sentences assez longue
ces gens là ont travaillé sur eux donc
on fait des programmes de réhabilitation
de réinsertion sociale ils ont travaillé
sur leur délit donc ils sont pas sans
potentiellement plus un danger pour la
société
et ça c'est l'initiative cette campagne
de sensibilisation lol avec les photos
et qu'on a vu si l'initiative du comité
consultatif pour la clientèle
judiciariser est ce qu'il ya une espèce
de garantie ou de tutorat est ce qu'un
accompagnement des gens qui se faire
embaucher par exemple pour 0 employeurs
veulent embaucher puis on a suivi avec
cette personne n'a écouté il ya des
organismes parce que le comité
consultatif pour la clarté a juste
réaliser regroupe des organisations qui
promu l'employabilité des personnes
incarcérées
donc ces gens là souvent ces organismes
là vont offrir un suivi vont accompagner
la personne dans la recherche d'emploi
ils vont l'orienter vers un emploi qui
peut potentiellement obtenir parce que
la réhabilitation ça pense comme vous
l'avez mentionné la part par non plus ça
passe par un emploi parce que si on veut
que les gens sortent de prison et
j'essaye de la société il faut
contribuer à la société il faut pas que
ces gens-là soient sur l'aide sociale
il faut que ce débat possible pour la
société donc s'élancer à ce mardi la
semaine de la réhabilitation sociale est
d'ailleurs une motion qui a été votée
cette semaine à l'assemblée nationale
pour que la semaine du 14 au 18 octobre
soit la semaine de la réhabilitation oui
ça a été fait par la ministre sécurité
publique et geneviève guilbault un avis
ça merci beaucoup mais c'est bensen
merci au revoir bonne journée saint john